the metoo movement with its believe all
women mantra fell by the wayside in
recent years thanks in part to the fact
that nobody could figure out what a
woman is it's hard to believe women if
you don't know
what is meant by the word i mean how can
i believe women if i don't know what you
mean when you say women
also of course the metoo movement chose
to put itself on pause conveniently
right around the time when a woman
accused joe biden of sexual assault this
was purely a coincidence no doubt the
metoo crusaders were just you know
exhausted they needed a vacation
and they took this vacation right at the
exact moment when the democrat
front-runner for the presidency was
accused of digitally raping one of his
aides when he was in the senate
that's entirely happenstance only a
conspiracy theorist would draw a
connection between the two
still
metoo's conspicuous silence only served
to further discredit a movement which
never should have had any credibility to
begin with
and in keeping with its habit of
disappearing and then reappearing at
politically convenient times
now it's back
just in the nick of time to take down
elon musk a reported business insider
which was eagerly picked up and
amplified by every mainstream media
outlet within minutes of course claims
that musk sexually harassed a flight
attendant
uh a few years ago reading from the
report it says
spacex the aerospace firm founded by
elon musk's musk the world's wealthiest
man paid a flight attendant 250 thousand
000 to settle a sexual misconduct claim
against musk in 2018 insider has learned
now we can stop right there
um just for a moment
we haven't made it past the first
sentence and already there are red flags
all over the place the first major and
ultimately disqualifying red flag is the
timing of all of this which we'll talk
more about in a moment
but the other is the amount that musk
allegedly paid to settle the claim
so think about that we'll return to that
point too
but the amount is very interesting for
now let's keep reading says the
attendant worked as a member of the
cabin crew on a contract basis for
spacex's corporate jet fleet she accused
musk of exposing his erect penis to her
rubbing her leg without consent and
offering to buy her a horse in exchange
for an erotic massage according to
interviews and documents obtained by
insider the incident which took place in
2016 is allegedly in a is alleged in a
declaration signed by a friend of the
attendant and prepared in support of her
claim the details in this story are
drawn from the declaration as well as
other documents including email
correspondence and other records shared
with insider by the friend
now it's explained that this flight
attendant who also had a license as a
massage therapist went back to musk's
cabin on his private jet to give him a
full body massage at which point she
claims or rather
someone else claims that she claims so
this is a claim being made on someone
else's behalf
so it's a she said she said situation
and the claim is that she was sexually
propositioned by musk who exposed
himself to her allegedly she refused
left the room and in the ensuing days
and weeks she alleges or her friend
alleges that she alleges she saw her
hours cut back at her job and she
determined that she was being pushed out
in retaliation
she was then supposedly paid 250 000 in
exchange for remaining silent about the
incident for his part musk says that
this is all a
politically motivated attack
and anybody with an iq above room
temperature can see that it is exactly
that
and we know this for a few reasons
first as mentioned
the amount of the alleged settlement
musk is worth
more than 200 billion dollars
if you have a legitimate harassment
claim against a man with pockets as deep
as that against against the richest man
in the history of the world in fact
then you would not take a measly 250
grand for your silence
for a billionaire 250 000 is what you
pay to get rid of a nuisance
the payment if there was a payment at
all
doesn't indicate that this woman
actually had career and life destroying
dirt on musk it indicates rather that
she was an annoyance to him and that
musk could deal with it by just sort of
throwing pennies at her pennies by his
standards anyway
but the bigger red flag of course
and the thing that just disqualifies the
whole story
right away
is the timing so let's follow the
timeline here
musk
makes an offer to buy twitter
the left is very upset put it mildly
then musk says that he's going to start
voting republican
the very next day
the media drops the sexual harassment
story the next day
the timing is not quite as transparent
as christine ford deciding that she was
raped by kavanaugh at precisely the
moment when kavanaugh was nominated at
the supreme court
but it's pretty close timing-wise
and this is the point
if you have a harassment or assault
claim to make against somebody
and you wait until a politically
expedient time to make it
even if it's true it's still your fault
when the claim is disbelieved and
dismissed
now this fake incident happened four
years ago this friend quote unquote had
four years to alert the world to the
horrific deeds committed by elon musk
four years to do instead she waited
until right after musk came out as a
republican
now musk himself predicted a few days
ago that the political attacks against
him would get worse and he was right
of course he was right
because we know that the left
will stop at nothing to punish anybody
who defies it
the more egregious your defiance the
worse the attack will be
the more effective you are in opposing
them the worse the attack will be
and if the attacks work right
if they succeed in turning public
opinion against someone with lies and
slander that only encourages them to do
it more
and to do it to more people
to claim more
victims that's why as a as a matter of
common sense
but also simply as a matter of self
preservation
our reflexive response to any
transparent left-wing smear campaign
must be to discount it dismiss it and
assume that it's false
we must do that even though on occasion
some of the dirt they throw around about
one of their targets may have an element
of truth to it
every once in a while who knows
like when they're trying to destroy
someone and they just start throwing
everything against the wall he did this
he did that
some of the stuff might be true who
knows
but we can't sift through the dirt
to try to discern what's true and what
isn't
that they've already won when you do
that
and you've encouraged them to continue
with these tactics in the future
if you have something to say about
somebody something to reveal you know a
deep dark secret you feel needs to be
brought into the public
don't dump it as part of a coordinated
political revenge campaign
if you do that you deserve to be ignored
and as for us again this is it's a it's
a matter of self-preservation
when the left starts doing this to
people
and they're only getting more egregious
they're getting more blatant about it
like what they just did to madison
cawthorn like if they don't like you
they're going to rip you apart they're
going to throw everything they have
and our only response should be simply
to just dismiss it
we're not going to pay attention to it
sorry nice try
moving on
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated